marée noire les bretons en colère ils
ont manifesté dans cinq villes il y a eu
des accidents à brest marée noire
toujours les groupes pétroliers sont ils
plus dangereux que les autres
le gigantisme en accusation les
difficultés des religieux en amérique
latine le témoignage de mon seigneur
pardonne
la jument une de mai est morte à 15 ans
seulement elle avait été la grande
championne du trot français bonsoir
ajoutée à tous ces titres évidemment
l'événement de la soirée en football
france-brésil au parc des princes
match retransmis en direct dans 25
minutes sur un thème de football samba
football fiesta c'est à qui trouvera le
qualificatif le plus typique pour ce
match le soleil et le ciel bleu qui ont
montré le bout de leur nez toute la
journée au dessus de paris ont laissé la
place à une soirée toute printanière
bref au parc des princes tout est en
place thierry roland pour la fête du
football je pense oui en effet le parc
des princes se remplit lentement mais
sûrement avec quelque 25 minutes du coup
d'envoi de cette rencontre amicale il
est bon de le préciser mais très
attendue car les brésiliens sont
toujours auréolé vous le savez d'un
prestige certain ils ont été trois fois
champion du monde ce sont les seuls à
être dans ce cas et cela leur confère
une auréole dans tout le monde du
football même si l'équipe actuelle du
brésil n'a pas en ce sens un homme de la
classe de pelé encore que l'on dise le
plus grand bien de ce zico que nous
allons découvrir comme nous allons
découvrir du reste la jeune équipe du
brésil qui n'a rien à envier à l'équipe
de france puisque c'est une équipe en
pleine transformation pour l'instant le
parc des princes est calme le parc des
princes regarde le match que les cadets
de france dispute contre leurs rivaux
suisse il mène du reste 3 0 les jeunes
cadets français avec sans doute celui
qui sera le grand joueur de demain il
n'a que 15 ans il s'appelle laurent
paganelli et il est à avignon dans les
cabines les reporter brésilien qui sont
venus en grand nombre comme toujours
pour le football car là bas c'est une
religion
ils se préparent eux aussi nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler et qui sait
peut-être de vous les montrer dans nos
prochaines éditions pour l'instant le
arqués calme on attend les exploits pour
tout à l'heure donc rendez-vous dans 25
minutes thierry roland pour le coup
d'envoi mais dès maintenant en
exclusivité antenne 2 vous révèle une
information qui va à la fois étonné et
réjouir je le pense
les 46 mille spectateurs qui seront
présents au parc des princes tout à
l'heure et les millions de
téléspectateurs qui vont suivre la
rencontre sur antenne 2 raymond kopa va
jouer ce soir avec l'équipe de france
michel hidalgo vous le savez a eu bien
des problèmes pour le onze tricolore 7
titulaires ont été blessés il fallait
donc faire appel à d'autres talents à
d'autres joueurs confirmés certains que
son expérience serait un atout
considérable face aux brésiliens michel
hidalgo a donc rappelé raymond kopa
effectivement la nouvelle vague et est
surprenante mais michel et la lgo déjà
m'avait téléphoné chez moi à deux
reprises en demandant si éventuellement
j'étais prêt pour jouer en équipe de
france contre le brésil
j'étais surpris bien sûr mais devant
l'hécatombe de blessures actuellement
jeudi 12 août michel demain je suis avec
les enseignes qui veut venger une rue de
voir si vraiment tu tues tu veux que je
joue alors en marche reprendrait
décision dernier moment ces décisions
devraient d'apprendre et je suis très
fier
que à la pensée que vraiment comparé à
46 ans pouvait encore jouer dans cette
équipe de france
ce qui va me permettre de retrouver ses
brésiliens se pose bien que je n'ai
jamais pu battre
peut-être ce soir c'est mon copain vous
mesurez ce soir le risque que vous
prenez de revenir en équipe de france
sur cette pelouse du parc des princes
que vous avez bien connu ce risque pour
votre popularité si vous manquez un
match pareil tout et je mesure ces
risques mais
pourquoi vouliez que même malgré mes
quarante six ans je m'entraîne deux très
souvent je suis en très bonne condition
physique
bien sûr je n'ai plus la vivacité car
l'âge de 20 ans mais enfin je pense que
j'ai suffisamment de ressources pour
pouvoir figurer honorablement en tous
les cas dans mon esprit c'est surtout
pour aider actuellement cette équipe de
france et plus particulièrement michel
gauthier m'a fait confiance revenant ont
des préoccupations plus terre à terre et
en particulier au prix de tout ce qui
compose généralement un petit déjeuner
le café d'abord une bonne nouvelle son
prix va baisser et -5% sur les cafés
solubles et -7% sur le café en grains le
lait 5% 5 centimes plus tôt en moyenne
par litre d'augmentation à paris par
exemple un litre de lait en bouteille
plastique souple en berlingots va coûter
un franc 97 le pain 10 centimes de plus
pour la baguette de 250 grammes et 20
centimes de plus pour le kilo de gros
pain et puis enfin un complément
habituel du petit déjeuner le journal
quotidien à paris ils vont tous augmenté
sauf le matin les l'humanité qui fixera
son nouveau prêt dans quelques jours le
figaro laurent or le quotidien de paris
et france soir coûteront désormais un
franc 60 le monde
un franc soixante dix et libération
l'idée un franc 81 la marée noire
manifestation contre la marée noire
aujourd'hui en bretagne à brest à
morlaix à lorient à saint brieuc et à
saint malo les bretons sont descendus
dans la rue pour manifester à brest en
particulier il y avait sept mille
personnes cet après midi dans la rue qui
avaient répondu à l'appel des syndicats
cgt cfdt et de la fen les manifestants
se sont rendus en cortège devant la
sous-préfecture et de légers incidents
se sont produits avec les forces de
police dans la soirée
et puis en bretagne la grande opération
nettoyage a véritablement commencé ce
week-end d'après les spécialistes
ce sera peut-être plus facile que pour
la marée noire du torrey canyon par
exemple dans certains endroits un jet
d'eau seulement permet de décaper les
rochers mais il ne faut pas oublier que
le naufrage de l'amoco cadiz a provoqué
tout de même le verse le déversement en
mer de 230 mille tonnes de brut de 130
mille tonnes c'est la capacité déjà d'un
supertanker mais il en existe de bien
plus gigantesque encore hervé claude à
l'occasion il ya trois mois de naviguer
pendant une semaine sur l'un de ces
monstres le plus gros bateau du monde le
voit si c'est un pétrolier français le
pierre guillaumat il ramène 550 mille
tonnes de pétrole à chaque voyage deux
fois plus que la moco k10 on a du mal à
réaliser sa taille véritable mais sachez
par exemple que sur son fond de 420
mètres de long on pourrait installer
quatre terrains de football ou encore on
peut le comparer à l'arc de triomphe de
l'étoile
et bien voilà ce que cela donne et cela
fait peur pourtant c'est vrai en matière
de sécurité
ces engins sont très au point exemple
deux ordinateurs sur le pierre
guillaumat dont un pour éviter les
collisions et surtout de moteurs de
gouvernail toutes les commandes en
double pour pallier un incident
mécanique
ça les rend beaucoup plus sûr que les
pétroliers de 200 mille tonnes type
amoco qu'à 10
même si ce n'est pas loin de là la seule
raison qui a dicté le choix des
compagnies pétrolières les raisons de
gestion sont importantes
je n'irai pas déterminant mais très
importante les gros pétroliers par
rapport aux 15 mille tonnes quand gagner
la bataille de l'atlantique représente
des économies de gestion considérable et
tout le monde en bénéficie le
consommateur le premier vous et moi
notre niveau de vie est un peu lié à ces
économies de transport
cette réseau est importante
une raison plus importante encore et
celle de la sécurité je crois
profondément que les gros pétroliers de
500 mille tonnes apporte une sécurité
supplémentaire de même que l'airbus par
exemple représente une économie de
risque considérable par rapport à 200
avions individuel par portant de deux
personnes qui voudraient atterrir au
même moment les gros pétroliers c'est la
même chose c'est la sécurité au fond des
transports en commun par rapport à une
multiplication transforme mutuelle oui
mais ces îles flottantes sont elles
adaptées au monde qui les entoure
exemple entre le havre et le golfe
persique 40 jours de navigation autour
de l'afrique
il n'y a aucun port qui puisse les
accueillir ils sont trop gros ils ne
peuvent jamais accoster autre exemple
les moteurs aussi gigantesque soit il
leur puissance relative reste faible
c'est comme si on manoeuvrait ayotte de
12 mètres avec un moteur d'un cheval
seulement et ces bateaux là entre dans
la manche la mer la plus fréquentée du
globe et passe à quelques kilomètres des
côtes bretonnes
le principal inconvénient est que
lorsque supertankers subi un incident
mécanique
il ne peut pas le surmonter une totale
corrigée
l'équipage est beaucoup trop petit
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir apporter une
aide valable et vous en avez la
démonstration avec un mot cool calix une
fois qu'il a cassé son gouvernail il n'a
pas pu bien entendu fait aucune
réparation ensuite même le remorqueur et
un des plus puissants d'europe
ce remorqueur n'a pas pu le tirer la
houssière a claqué le bateau est trop
gros pour le remorqueur est trop gros
pour au fond toute espèce de mesures de
sauvetage pourrait pas empêcher le
naufrage
depuis deux ans par exemple le nombre
des accidents a augmenté dans le
transport maritime
ce n'est sans doute pas à cause des très
gros bateaux mais c'est super tanker ne
sont à l'abri ni du hasard ni l'erreur
une alors on peut dire en reprenant la
comparaison avec le trafic aérien dans
la vie les accidents de pétroliers
seront sans doute moins fréquent mais le
gigantisme rendre à leurs conséquences
beaucoup plus graves
tout au long de la semaine sur antenne 2
et en particulier dans notre magazine
question de temps mercredi dernier nous
avons essayé de vous montrer les
conséquences économiques de cette
pollution de cette marée noire
ce soir nous allons nous arrêter sur le
cas des goémoniers ces ramasseurs de
goémon dont l'activité a été réduite à
néant depuis le naufrage une activité un
métier compromis maintenant pour de
longs mois
jean-marc il use voici le ramassage du
goémon algues et deux rives où le rivage
désormais utilisés dans l'industrie
legault m ou fait vivre plusieurs
centaines de familles en bretagne de
l'île de batz à portsall 80% de la
production française
la récolte devait commencer le 15 avril
mais désormais tout est compromis
nous sommes dans le vrai car l âge mais
maintenant nous pouvons plus rien faire
parce que les bateaux sont pollués on
vous le voyez ici tous les bateaux sont
en noir de mazout allons d'eads a aussi
une a tenté en vain de se protéger mais
il est déjà trop tard pour le goémon de
plage et si demain la moisson de goémon
de fonds est également souillé la vie
s'arrêtera
on ne pourra plus vendre à l' usine une
soixantaine de personnes travaillent ici
à la préparation des farines d'algues et
des alginate composants au bruit très
usité par les industries alimentaires et
pharmaceutiques et largement exporté
pour préserver demain leur pureté il
faudra vraisemblablement aller pêcher
loin de l' usine dans le sud finistère
un pari nécessaire mais qu'il sera
difficile de tenter seul
c'est cela va poser des problèmes
considérables d'abord au niveau du
transport de l'hébergement des pêcheurs
dans ces lieux éloignés de leur domicile
au niveau de l' usine en ce qui concerne
les transports
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que
c'est une matière première qui ne se
conserve pas au delà de 24 heures que
nous sommes donc contraints de la
transporter et de la mettre en
fabrication aussitôt alors nous nous
employons avec les pêcheurs les bretons
sont que c'est connu sont des peines
khaled comme on dit ils n'ont pas peur
de retrousser les manches
on le dit les français le savent mais ça
ne suffit pas nous comptons bien saoulé
sur les pouvoirs publics pour qu'ils
nous aident véritablement ce que l'on
craint le plus c'est que le goémon
mazout et disparaissent au profit des
espèces plus résistantes mais non
exploitables commercialement il faut
trois ans un plan de goémon pour
renaître et personne ne peut prédire
comment réagir à un monde sous-marin
bouleversé même pas les experts
américains de la pollution par
hydrocarbures a couru pour épauler leurs
collègues français
ils ne cachent pas leur impuissance bhv
fax table et fait du mazout vont se
manifester de façon différente dans
certains coins les alpes seront apurés
simplement été ailleurs illégaux et
mourra les apparences de la santé mais
une fois étalé sur un rocher il
présentera un aspect est régulièrement
brillante parce qu il sera malade de
pesci nous autres chercheurs on se sent
vraiment dépassé ce matin à landéda on
ne voulais pas désespérer la semaine
prochaine on tentera quand même de
moissonner les algues de faire procéder
à de nouvelles analyses
si les résultats sont négatifs le coût
sera très dur ici le goémon c'est aussi
une manière de vivre
nous souhaitons qu'une chance campus
rails
ce que nous nommons nous n'aimons pas
beaucoup être secours les bretons eux
sont faits pour travailler
ils ne demandent qu'à travailler être
payés pour leur travail et non vivre
dedans
d'ailleurs si l'on peut pas travailler
nous n'acceptons pas dedans nous nous
demandons des indemnisations réel de
perte de manque à gagner
un reportage de jean marc il use
félicitations monsieur raymond barre
c'est le chancelier allemand helmut
schmidt qui les créent dans un
télégramme envoyé au premier ministre à
l'occasion de sa nouvelle désignation à
la tête du gouvernement hier je me
réjouis sincèrement que cette charge
lourde de responsabilités est à nouveau
été déposé entre vos mains
du côté de l'hôtel matignon bien peu de
nouvelles aujourd'hui monsieur raymond
barre a parait-il travail et une grande
partie de la journée seules à son bureau
officiellement pas de consultation nous
n'allons pas douter les téléphones ne
devrait pas manquer de ce n'est au cours
de ce week-end précédent la formation du
nouveau gouvernement
le docteur wadie haddad est mort mardi
dernier à l'âge de 50 ans le nom de cet
homme ne vous dira sans doute pas grand
chose sauf si j'ajoute que c'est lui qui
avait imaginé pour le front populaire de
libération de la palestine le
détournement d'avion de zarqa en 70 la
fusillade de l'aéroport de l'aude plus
de 20 morts
le détournement de l'airbus d'air france
sur en tb le cerveau du terrorisme
palestinien est mort dans un hôpital
d'allemagne de l'est d'un cancer premier
président américain à se rendre en
afrique noire jimmy carter est arrivé la
nuit dernière à lagos au nigeria dès son
arrivée dans un discours il a lancé un
appel contre toutes les interventions
étrangères sur le continent africain
pourquoi avoir choisi le nigeria comme
but de son voyage philippe rochot nous
l'expliquent
le nigeria le pays le plus peuplé
d'afrique avec 75 millions d'habitants
une grande première pour jimmy carter il
y a deux ans à peine
enrique singer était déclarée
indésirable ici mais aujourd'hui le
régime du général obasanjo est favorable
à la politique africaine de jimmy carter
oui à la règle de la majorité noire en
afrique australe
non au genre de règlement qui vient
d'intervenir en rhodésie entre ian smith
et les dirigeants noirs modéré le régime
du général obasanjo est même considéré
par jimmy carter comme un modèle
d'ouverture en afrique car il a décidé
de passer le pouvoir aux civils
l'an prochain le nigeria est aussi le
deuxième fournisseur de pétrole des
etats-unis après l'arabie séoudite mais
ce pays le plus riche de l'afrique de
l'ouest connaît les misères de
l'abondance les bateaux par exemple met
plus de trois mois à décharger leur
cargaison dans le port de lagos et le
nigeria accueille sans goudé la
coopération américaine dans l'actualité
encore ces quelques télégrammes le baron
empain est parti se reposait la campagne
dans une résidence tenue secrète
hier soir au quai des orfèvres il a tenu
à remercier les policiers des brigades
criminels et de l'antigang qui ont
participé à sa libération
et aujourd'hui après l'entretien de
quatre heures avec le juge d'instruction
il a décidé de se constituer partie
civile
un satellite de plus dans l'espace c'est
le millième de la série cosmos satellite
soviétique qui a pour mission dit on à
moscou d'accroître la sécurité de la
navigation maritime
s'il pouvait éviter des catastrophes de
ce type de l'amoco cadiz ce serait fort
bien et puis la providence on a appuyé
on a appris ce matin 1er avril la mort
de une deux mais la jument qui était
devenu la coqueluche des turfiste en 68
vedette mondiale une de mai était
incontestablement l'une des plus grande
jument qui est contée l'élevage français
81 victoires dont une trentaine à
l'étranger une de mes avait 15 ans et la
majeure partie de sa carrière s'était
faite sous la direction du pape de
vincennes jean rené gougeon
il y a quelques mois elle avait mis au
monde pour la première fois une
ravissante pouliche alezane son lad
était littéralement fou d'une demeure
commune mais on est obligé de la mer
elle vous connais je crois avait jugé
qu'à à l'appeler au sifflet regard de
sitôt et vous n'appelez pas comme vous
l'appelez ou ne plaît pas une deux mais
jamais non jamais une vie on la fait
tous de la même mère
pour vous c'est comme si c'était
quelqu'un de votre famille oh oui oui je
crois oui parce que je vous jure que
vraiment je laime beaucoup parce que
j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions avec
elle j'ai fait des beaux voyages mam a
beaucoup donné un vraiment elle m'a
changé ma vie une deux mais n'avait
jamais gagné le prix d'amérique tant
convoité une de mes un nom qui a fait
rêver bien des tur fils
une devait se l'est dans l'or une de mes
partenaires à la célèbre écurie du comte
de montesson et de l'argent elle en
avait gagné beaucoup presque 1 milliards
d'anciens francs en fin de carrière
adieu mais merde y résident rhône sur
ces images et il ajouterait certainement
qu'au royaume des chevaux une de mai a
déjà sa place
football pour commencer journal football
pour le terminer à l'image de ce qui
s'est passé cet après midi sur la
pelouse du stade jean bouin football
non-stop
après un match de lever de rideau ou une
nouvelle fois les journalistes de radios
et les télés se sont fait battre par
leurs collègues de la presse écrite sont
en très précisément sur la pelouse vingt
ans après les joueurs qui avait fait les
beaux jours de l'équipe de france de ce
fait et louis ils étaient tous là cet
après midi ceux qui sont entrés dans la
légende sous le nom des anciens de suite
bien sûr les temps pour légèrement
blanchi les insensible à l'irréparable
outrage des gens ils n'auront pas moins
charme et leurs fidèles ceux qui par la
pensée on fait avec eux la campagne de
suède il ya vaincu pour leur donner la
réplique il avait fait appel à des
artistes et à des sportifs du se sont
illustrés dans beauf discipline à la mi
temps les deux équipes étaient à égalité
0-0 mais dans une deuxième mi temps les
anciens de suède retrouvant les
automatismes d'antan marqué trois buts
deux de copa qui coupent ainsi
pleinement sa sélection contre le brésil
et un de jean jacques marseille en face
ce n'était pas la débandade est loin de
là quand le bouquet retrouvé son punch
martin
et françois jauffret sur penalty réussi
ce qu'on est ce un pas de la victoire
restait comme anciens qui avaient
retrouvé leur âme de 20 ans à l'image de
remettre voilà très rapidement
maintenant deux mots de la météo pour
demain c'est simple de la pluie un peu
partout en france sauf sur le nord et
sur l'est de la france où dans l'après
midi il y aura du soleil une information
aussi très important vous savez qu'il ya
un changement d'horaire la nuit
prochaine à 2 heures il sera 3 heures
c'est à dire que vous allez pousser
votre montre je vais faire très très
très rapidement on va la fée café 30 à 2
heures il sera 3 heures donc et vous
poussez votre montre d'une heure pour
qu'on se retrouve à la bonne heure
demain
de toute façon vous avez rendez vous
avec hervé claude à 23h50 ce soir pour
le dernier journal
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
sur antenne 2